reaching for these Gordon Brown style  tools of desperation was what made me  write this cover story in the first  place I looked at it this is incredibly  complacent of the Tories if you think  this staggeringly unambitious platform  because in any way be described as a  pledge the only ambitious thing they  mentioned was stopping the small boats  stopping a small boats not reducing the  half of Landings by half now there's no  way he's going to be able to if he is I  will take my hat off to him so it seemed  to me to be four fantasies and an  undeliverable and that is his New Year's  resolution for 2023 it's going to be a  very difficult  um year for the tourism did